men don't care about IQ what do you
think I really strongly disagree with
that if it was the case that women care
about male intelligence but men don't
care about female intelligence you'd get
a huge sex difference in intelligence
but in fact if you look at intelligence
research it seems like the Sexes are
extremely close in terms of general
intelligence so I think what's going on
is when men are looking for short-term
like a hookup then yeah you don't care
about the woman's intelligence because
if it's just about the guy getting a
notch on his belt what does it matter
how smart she is however there's good
evidence that when men are getting more
serious about choosing a long-term mate
men get much more selective about
intelligence than they are for hookups
and we see this in the data on assorted
of mating when people pair up they tend
to match with someone with similar IQ